في طريق الانتخابات القادمه لا تالوا
القوى السياسيه التركيه جهدا في كسب اكبر
عدد من الاصوات كل القضايا الاشكاليه منها
وغير الاشكاليه مطروحه على الطاوله والهدف
واحد تسجيل نقاط اكثر في ميدان الخصوم
السياسيين
ومجددا الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان يتحدث عن
طرح حزبه مجموعه من التعديلات الدستوريه
للبرلمان ركز فيها على ملف حريه ارتداء
المراه للحجاب في محاوله لحشد دعم شعبي
قبل الانتخابات المقبله
[تصفيق]
بدا اصدقاءنا مناقشه اقتراح التعديل
الدستوري الذي اعددناه مع كل من حزب
الحركه القوميه شريكنا في تحالف الشعب
والاحزاب السياسيه الاخرى التي لها كتله
في البرلمان وبعد المشاورات سننتهي من
اقتراحنا وسنعرضه على البرلمان
المعارضه رفضت التعديل الدستوري لكنها
حاولت اللعب على نفس الوتر باقتراح تشريع
من البرلمان يضمن للمراه حريه ارتداء
الحجاب لكن حزب العداله والتنميه الحاكم
يتمسك بتمرير هذه القضيه عبر الدستور
متابعون للشان التركي يرون ان هذه القضيه
تاتي في سياق تنافس انتخابي على كسب اصوات
المحافظين فكله الطرفين متفقان على قضيه
الحجاب لكن الاختلاف ما بين تشريع برلماني
او تعديل الدستوري ما هو الا في سياق سعي
الى مكاسبا انتخابيه
مره اخرى طبعا له علاقه جدا بالانتخابات
التي تقترب اعتقد بان الاحزاب جميعها تريد
ان تجذب اصوات الناخبين ناسيه من الطبقه
المحافظه التي تشكل الاغلبيه في تركيا
فالموضوع اصلا محل يعني همم موضوع الحجاب
في تركيا منذ سنوات والمحجبات يعملن في
الاماكن العامه
وتشمل التعديلات الدستوريه التي يعمل حزب
العداله والتنميه على تحضيرها قبل عرضها
على البرلمان وجود نص في الدستور يضمن
للمراه حريه ارتداء الحجاب اضافه الى
تعديل دستوري ينص على ان الاسره مكونه من
رجل وامراه بهدف منع اي خطوات مستقبليه
لتشريع الزواج بين المثليين في تركيا
رغم ان قضيه الحجاب قديمه في تركيا ويرى
كثير من المحللين انها باتت من الماضي بعد
سنوات من الغاء حظر الحجاب في الجامعات
والمؤسسات الحكوميه لكن طرحها اليوم بقالب
وشكل جديد يؤشر الى ان كل طرف سياسيا
متمسكن باوراق يعتقد انها تصب في مصلحته
لاستهداف جمهور معين بغي يتجا مزيدا من
الاصوات زيدان زينجو العربيه اسطنبول